this video was made possible by dashlane
stay safe online for free by signing up
at dashing calm slash Wendover this is
Hong Kong 177 years ago as the
conclusion of the First Opium War the
United Kingdom and China signed a treaty
that read His Majesty the Emperor of
China seems to Her Majesty the Queen of
Great Britain etc the island of Hong
Kong to be possessed in perpetuity by
her Britannic Majesty her heirs and
successors and to be governed by such
laws and regulations as Her Majesty the
Queen of Great Britain etc shall see fit
to direct with that the British Empire
got just a little bit bigger the
population of the island in that year
was reported as 7450 nobody would have
imagined what this island dotted only by
a few fishing villages would become
fast-forward eighteen years
another opium war another treaty it has
now been agreed between the governments
of Great Britain and China that the
limits of British territory shall be
enlarged under lease fast-forward 38
years the third and final agreement it
has now been agreed between the
governments of Great Britain and China
but the limits of British territory
shall be enlarged under lease to the
extent indicated generally on the
annexed map the term of this lease shall
be 99 years 99 years as good as forever
to the signers of this Agreement this
forever though had an end and that end
was 1997 that didn't matter at first
though Hong Kong grew and grew and grew
and grew into one of the richest most
powerful and most developed cities in
the world
it became the business center of Asia it
thrived under a strong capitalistic
economic model but then as forever drew
near a question loomed over the city was
it really going back to China
that's the question British Prime
Minister Margaret Thatcher had for
densho ping China's paramount leader
when she visited Beijing in 1982 the
answer was effectively yes in China's
eyes Hong Kong would return in 1997 now
it's important to note that it is only
the lease of this portion the new
territories that expired in 1997 Kowloon
and Hong Kong Island were ceded in
perpetuity which meant that according to
the terms of the agreements are ittan
could have kept these areas Hong Kong as
a whole though is small enough already
and the city had very much grown into
the new territories so it was decided
early
that these negotiations were effectively
over what would happen to Hong Kong as a
whole it would be too impractical to
divide up the quite integrated city into
different parts eventually after years
of back-and-forth a decision was reached
in the last days of 1984 Hong Kong would
go back to China in 1997 for the Hong
Kong way of life with a capitalistic
system and democratic government would
remain untouched for 50 years after the
handover until 2040 7 Hong Kong would
become a semi autonomous region of China
with that a clock started ticking there
were 12 years 6 months and 12 days left
until Hong Kong would change from
British to Chinese in those 12 and a
half years an enormous amount of
planning and preparation was conducted
in order to carry out one of the only
modern instances of the change in
sovereignty of a city as large and
influential as Hong Kong between two
countries so different in fact this was
the first time a capitalistic territory
had been handed over to a communist
state conducting such a monumental shift
was no easy feat as such a significant
business hub Hong Kong based companies
were some of the first to make their
handover plans there was at the time a
loss of uncertainty about what would
happen to the territory post hand over
so many companies restructure to be
legally registered elsewhere Jordi
Matheson for example one of the most
prominent Hong Kong companies move their
legal headquarters to Bermuda and their
stock listing to Singapore even if their
de facto headquarters remained in Hong
Kong HSBC which stands for the Hong Kong
and Shanghai Banking Corporation legally
transferred many of their assets to
their London office as well companies
typically didn't leave Hong Kong but
rather set themselves up to be able to
in case the handover went badly in
addition to companies individual people
made their handover plans as well now
opinions were mixed on this grand change
there was no one resounding view on
whether the change in sovereignty was
good or bad for Hong Kong when surveyed
in 1991 for example about 57% of
respondents were confident in Hong
Kong's future while 35% were not of
those 35% who were not many chose to
move elsewhere and there began a period
of mass migration away from Hong Kong a
staggering 800,000 people left in the
twelve and a half years leading up to
the handover according to estimates
overwhelmingly Hong Kong are settled in
Australia or Canada like
because they were Commonwealth countries
and the US over 110,000 Hongkonger
settled in Vancouver alone a city still
shaped by this wave of mass migration
many though were just migrating
temporarily for a few years to gain
Canadian citizenship with this like
companies they would have a way to get
out of Hong Kong if things went wrong
Hong Kong Greece could also get a
special type of passport that was first
introduced in 1985 in the lead up to the
handover it was called the British
national overseas passport and it works
differently to a British passport
it gives visa-free access to 118
countries fewer than a full British
passport and noticeably does not give
the right for someone to live and work
in the UK holders can only stay in the
UK for up to six months and are not
considered European Union citizens these
passports are still valid today and can
be renewed for anyone bored in Hong Kong
prior to the handover there was a huge
and increasing rush of people at
registration for these passports in the
years leading up to the handover with
millions overall being issued while
today's Hong Kong Special Administrative
Region passport is more powerful in
terms of visa-free access to countries
holders and British national overseas
passports as British nationals get the
same consular assistance and protection
as a full British citizen in case a
holder runs into trouble outside the UK
at least on paper for this reason
hundreds of thousands still renew these
passports to this day despite the
redundancy as the date of the handover
Junior though the government started
focusing on the changes they needed to
make of course there were enormous
changes to the entire structure of
government the laws the legal system and
more but there were also small changes
to be made plenty of which were visual
for example they needed a new flag the
previous flag which included the British
Union Jack certainly wouldn't work under
Chinese rule a contest was held with
7,000 submissions but all were rejected
in the end one of the contest judges
architect aho came up with this design
which was eventually approved to be the
new flag in April 1919 but there were
plenty of other signs of Britishness in
Hong Kong the emblem of the police force
included a crown and the word royal so
that had to be changed too they
eventually came up with a new design
that swapped out the British tin moles
and replaced the uniforms at a cost of
2.8 million u.s. dollars the word royal
in fact was removed from basically every
institution from the royal hong kong
jockey club to the royal
golf club they just became the Hong Kong
jockey club and the Hong Kong golf club
there was just plenty of sign changing
city wide Hong Kong's post boxes were
another symbol that needed altering most
at the time were imported from Britain
and therefore were the iconic red pillar
Park style featuring a crown
most of these were progressively removed
with all being painted green to
distinguish them from the UK's as the
days of British rule dwindled focus
shifted towards planning the actual
event of the handover now this event was
of enormous significance Tong Kong China
Britain and the world the BBC described
it as the biggest planned event they had
ever covered what was known was that the
event would be centered around midnight
on the night of July 30th 1997 the exact
moment of the reversion to Chinese rule
as you can imagine the two governments
Britain and China each crucially
desiring the best possible optics for
their side negotiated relentlessly on
the details of the event for example
there was a long dispute on which flags
would raise and lower in which order
Britain wanted the British Hong Kong
flag lowered first followed by the Union
Jack to signify a dignified retreat from
the colony China wanted the Chinese flag
to be raised at the same time as the
British flag was lowered to signify an
instantaneous resumption in sovereignty
China also wanted the new Hong Kong flag
to replace the British Hong Kong flag on
the same flagpole in the end a
compromise was reached to lower the
Union Jack and the British Hong Kong
flags at the same time then raised the
Chinese and new Hong Kong flags at the
same time there were other subtle
negotiated details such as the
Convention Center where the event was
held was designed to have chairs facing
South Twista stage for this event though
a stage was built on the north side so
the attendees would look north possibly
for the symbolism of looking towards
China eventually though the meticulously
negotiated invites went out to thousands
of dignitaries and VIPs one week before
the handover the Royal Yacht Britannia
sailed into Victoria Harbour and moored
to the pier it would serve as home to
Prince Charles who would represent the
United Kingdom during the handover over
the next week a majority of the
handovers VIPs including Prince Charles
then British Prime Minister Tony Blair
former British Prime Minister Margaret
Thatcher American Secretary of State
Madeleine Albright and plenty more
arrived in the city that week was a week
of lasts the last meeting of the Hong
Kong Executive Council
the last changing of the gaurd to the
British garrison and then it was just
the last day of Britain in Hong Kong
Monday June 30th 1997 the process kicked
off with a 4:00 p.m. ceremony at
Government House marking the final
departure of Chris Patten the last
governor of Hong Kong from what had been
his official residence for the previous
five years at 4:30 the first of his
goodbyes was completed and he was driven
to the Royal Yacht Britannia to join the
rest of the British delegation shortly
after around 5:30 a chartered air China
747 touched down at Kai Tak Airport
carrying Chinese president jeong's a
Ming Premier Li Peng and the rest of the
Chinese delegation then at 7:11 p.m. the
sunset on British Hong Kong for the
final time
minutes later the 4,000 lucky
individuals invited to the handover
ceremony gathered at the convention
centre for a cocktail reception at a
p.m. an enormous fireworks display
started in Victoria Harbour and then at
9:00 the handover guests sat down for
their banquet dinner at the Convention
Center simultaneously around 500 Chinese
people Liberation Army troops were
allowed over the border to move into
position and ensure that there would
never be a lapse in the defense of Hong
Kong at 30 minutes to midnight dinner
was over and the ceremony began Prince
Charles gave remarks pinning the
territory goodbye on behalf of the Queen
and then about a minute to midnight God
Save the Queen was played and the
British and British Hong Kong flags were
slowly and simultaneously lowered just
as negotiated then in an instant when
the clock struck midnight Hong Kong was
Chinese again just like that the new
Hong Kong and Chinese flags were then
raised to the Chinese national anthem
and Chinese president jeong's a Ming
gave a speech 15 minutes past midnight
Prince Charles and Governor Chris Patten
for the Royal Yacht Britannia and sailed
out a Victoria Harbour for the final
time Prime Minister Tony Blair and most
of the rest of the British delegation
then boarded a chartered British Airways
triple7 at Kai Tak Airport which swiftly
took off bound for London Heathrow by
3:30 a.m. all the British forces tasked
with guarding Hong Kong until midnight
had boarded flights and taken off from
the Chinese territory and with that
Britain was gone from Hong Kong for good
whenever I talk about - laying the
password manager on here people have one
major question what if - Lane gets
hacked the idea behind - Lane is that
you store complicated passwords ones you
could never remember unique to each site
you use
on it so that if one of the sites you
use gets compromised all your other
accounts are safe
how - Ling works is that you remember
one master key to get in that - lien
doesn't store only you have it so that
even if - lien was compromised a hacker
would still have to go one by one
through each user account and figure out
the passwords out through brute force
something that would take heaps of time
and never be worth it compared to other
targets that's why - Lang is so safe and
since it auto fills each of your secure
passwords for you on your devices it's
also quite convenient you can manage
your passwords using dash line for free
at dashing calm slash Wendover they also
have a whole suite of online security
tools included with their premium
package including a VPN dark web
monitoring encrypted file storage and
more which you can get for 10% off by
using the code Wendover at checkout